de cette histoire de montréal c'est
presque bientôt 35 ans d'histoire en 35
ans d'histoire besson pluriel parce que
depuis 35 ans le sentiment à bord d une
multitude de sujets dans des expositions
et activités scolaires des des parcours
pédestres des visites guidées et on se
dit mon dieu ce matériel là on peut pas
le garder pour nous et le sauna pour les
visiteurs sans histoire donc on a décidé
de mettre en ligne
beaucoup de ces contenus qu'on avait sur
nos tablettes sont peu dire qu'on avait
dans nos expositions exposition qui
roule qui change
on a eu des expositions sur leurs
lettres sur les quartiers de super u la
communauté portugaise et d'autres et
d'autres vont alors se dit tiens il faut
absolument créer un site vraiment actuel
ou de semaines en semaines
on va déposer des contenus qu'on ne crée
sont très très très soudaine parce qu'on
a des vrais historiens des chercheurs
sont en arrière de ça mais qui sont en
même temps extrêmement sympathique et
agréable à consulter parce que il ya des
images magnifiques du passé et du passé
lointain et du passé récent il ya des
entrevues avec des gens qui ont connu
des époques
il ya des petites capsules qui nous
permet rapidement de faire le tour d'une
question d'une petite histoire et le
site il est présenté de façon très
accessible parce qu'on peut faire des
recherches par thème par mots clés on
peut consulter aussi une carte de
montréal on retrouve pointée les
éléments du vêtement dont on parle donc
c'est vraiment un plaisir de rentrer la
mémoire des montréalais et on peut dire
puis moi j'ai vécu même si je suis un
petit peu lié à ce projet là qu'une fois
qu'on rentre dans mes moments des
montréalais vient des chances qu'on en
sort pas avant de longues minutes si
pour pas dire peut-être au moins une
heure alors bon exploration